from the worldwide leader in sports uh
and jeff van gundy how are you jeff
good what's going on i don't know you
know i could talk i'm gonna give you
dealer's choice
okay i'm gonna deal it out you're my uh
you're my guest so you tell me
do you wanna talk hardcore nba or
something silly i've noticed about the
nba that i'm keen to get your opinion on
which one do you want first
jeff let's start silly okay let's start
silly i've noticed
that uh in the bubble uh nba head
coaches stop wearing suits
and now that they're out of the bubble
they're still not wearing suits um
what was this a conscious decision by
nba head coaches to just
no longer wear suits and and does this
mean they never wanted to wear a suit
what is the deal with it jeff what's the
deal well i
think they had to get league approval
because i think there is a dress code
i know back there is a dress code that
the league relaxed
uh for this um for the bubble and for
that
and i just think what's next is the
coach is trying to monetize it somehow
and instead of wearing team gear you
know
they hey why not you know they sell the
patches on the
the jerseys why not sell the the the
front patch
of the sweatsuit for you know the
coaches to make some cash
i'm all for it huh and then so um
the league had a dress code that
you had to be dressed in a suit with a
tie like it would it was actually
codified
yeah not a tie i think it was suit coats
i i don't think you could wear sneakers
okay um
right yeah yeah so i think it was that
like my brother tried to get away with
like mock turtlenecks which thankfully
the league
immediately banned because it looked
awful
um so they did us a favor on that one
right uh but i'm not i i don't know if
they
if they're planning on relying uh greg
popovich has long been uh
trying to pass this like there should be
more informal wear for
the coaches yeah some so pop has been
leading the charge to get out of the
suits
yeah the guy huh he's been one of them
yeah i think there's
a lot of guys who like it and i think
there's other people who think it looks
more dignified
uh to be you know dressed up and then
there was me
who you could put me in sweats or in a
suit and i still look rumpled
so it didn't really matter well that's a
problem uh jeff
but you know that might be for for
another day does your brother
love he's loving the the dress down or
or what is he the
what is he yeah you know what like
i think he absolutely does like before
you know it he may be with flip-flops
over there on the sideline you know with
some snacks on a table too you never
know
just set up with like a barker lounger
did coach
you got plenty of room now there's six
feet between you
like i think everybody should have
individualized snacks over there
you know and just be able to order from
like especially the guys that know
they're not going in
like you know order a hot dog and you
know like
get some drinks yeah why not so the the
the dnp
cd guys are in charge of getting the
drinks because they know the coach's
decision is there's no chance of them
playing
so you use them as a de facto wait staff
for the dress down coaches jeff that's
the truth why not
why not like let's make it totally like
chill over there you know like
especially these places that have some
fans but not too many
think about the extra money the weight
staff
could earn in tips if they're getting if
they're
like serving millionaires on the bench
i think we have come up with something
so the last uh
item on this uh this topic jeff do you
think the nba does eventually save
to heck with it we want you back and
suited and booted and that would
literally lead to a conversation between
the coaches association and the nba on
on this subject matter
jeff for real i think the league will go
back to suit and ties
okay and i think that there will be uh
uh
a vote amongst the coaches on like
i think at least half would would hope
that they could
continue to dress uh as they are and
and more like football coaches on the
sidelines
you know like that type of gear i think
i think i think it would be great if it
was like a really cold arena
and you know you could come out there in
a hoodie too like
like cut off the sleeves cut off the
sleeves
come on how good would my brother look
like in that like just
[Laughter]
that would be fantastic i'd pay i'd
actually pay hard-earned american
dollars
to see why not i would actually pay
that's right to see something like that
my gosh that would be something else we
we think quinn schneider's a guy that
might break
we think out of all the head coaches
right now just say screw it i'm going to
put a suit back on i don't care
just do it like he's he he's our he's
our pick
you know there's there's people like
like quinn snyder
irritates me in this way right he looks
good
no matter what he puts on like you know
he could he can dress down
he looks stylish when he wore his suit
he looked great
like he wears like jeans around the
bubble you know
he looks terrific and then like i said
before then you got me
there's not one thing you can put me in
that makes me look dignified i i
i it irritates me you know and i think
it's also quinn's hair too right
of course you shouldn't have that good a
team and that good hair
you should have to sacrifice one or the
other if you're going to have a great
team
the hair has got to start falling out if
you're going to if you want a
a like a mediocre team then you can have
that flowing
locks but you can't have both i don't
know i think he thinks he can have it
all jeff
i think i'm seeing that there should be
a league rule is what i'm saying
like adam silver should say like all
right you got to pick
bad team or the hair's got to come off
why don't you shave your head what would
he he he what would he pick though
oh everybody's going to pick the good
team like listen
all right it is literally think about
what like the rockets are going through
right now 12 in a row
like the pain of that
is i don't think people understand the
pain
that is involved when you're not getting
the results you want
right and so yeah i mean
there's not one person that would pick
hair over
over wins just sacrifice some body parts
like if you would have said
okay like
[Laughter]
you know my like how valuable are toes
for a 10-game winning streak all right
yeah
i might take oh you can have one or two
yeah
the mindset of a coach jeff van gundy
here uh
on the rich eisen show i guess then it's
a perfect segue to quinn snyder's team
how good are the jazz
when it's all said and done what do you
think here jeff
well statistically when you look at them
they're absolutely dominant you know top
five in offense top five in defense
uh their bench even though other than
clarkson they don't have big names
uh clarkson and ingles like
fortify that bench the starting unit
plays terrific at both ends
i think the eye test
to me is there's no
there's no doubt they're a great team do
they have
the ability to get a bucket late in
more physical playoff games against the
best defenses
i think they do but that's the to me the
thing that
i want to see come play off time you
know you remember
last year in the bubble they were up
three one against denver
you know couldn't get the necessary
stops now they didn't have bogdanovic
then
uh so that's a big that was a big loss
but you know i think
playoff basketball is a little bit
different but i'm all in on the jazz i
think they're
a great great team so then the best team
in los angeles
is you could fill in the blank there
what do you got for me
well i think right now you'd have to say
the clippers um
from a talent standpoint but the one
thing
uh when davis comes back that
the lakers have they have a a quickness
at the point guard
uh and i think schroeder will continue
to play better and better as the year
goes on
but what they have besides the trump
card in james
and uh you know another trump card in
davis
they guard they're they're the best
defensive team in the league
and the clippers i think have the chance
to be a great defensive team
but right now they're sort of in the
middle of the pack they're pretty good
but not great
i think that they can make the next step
towards being a great defensive team
and they have talent to be a great
defensive team then
um you know they'll be on par with the
lakers
jeff fangun espn uh analyst um and um
with breen and mark jackson one of the
the best uh tan uh trios in in
all of sports broadcasting here on the
rich eisen show so um the nets without
durant have just caught fire
hardened with a seventh triple-double
zero turnovers
30 points and 15 assists and uh
14 rebounds my gosh um it
is this um the team to be when it's all
said and done as we approach the
all-star game this weekend
jeff well i their talent is as good as
anybody you know their top end talent
you know the depth part we'll see i'm
interested to see
if and what they add to their roster
between now uh and the start of the
playoffs
uh but certainly in the eastern
conference they have the
the most high-end talent i still think
milwaukee is outstanding
um they got off to a little bit slower
start
but uh giannis and middleton and holiday
has been out
for a long period of time with uh
covered product
protocols and all that but i think when
they get him incorporated
they're going to be a hard uh and
difficult team to beat as well so
i'm interested to see what the nets do
um
but harden you know there may be some
who didn't like how he
forced his way out of houston um
my counter to that would be if he
behaved correctly he wouldn't have got
they would have never you know traded
him
but one thing you can't deny is
he is an all-time great player and
he's easily one of the four best two
guards
to have ever played this game i mean
this guy
is phenomenal and his ability
at the two guard position to morph into
a point guard
uh absolutely control uh the flow of a
game
um can make every pass
you know shoots it with range gets to
the free throw line at it
incredibly high rate so yeah he's he's
been a great player for a long time and
he's
now in that spotlight once again
where he's with a great team who's
getting heavily covered
and people are seeing that greatness on
a nightly basis all right you just
strolled into that
that sweet spot for sports talk radio
program jeff where
you you you just said what top uh
with three or four two guards we're
assuming jordan and kobe are the other
part of them if it's and wade dwyane
wade you put there huh
oh yeah i think dwyane wade you know the
i don't think people really
because they remember they always
remember you at the end of your career
but dwyane wade
like pre lebron coming there when lebron
was there
and even when he took on that six-man
role i mean
it was greatness like a guy was
and this was without the the every night
three-point shooting range that these
you know you know like that a harden has
but
one of the greatest shot blocking two
guards of all time
had those point guard skills like um
harden um incredible off the ball cutter
you know i i thought his intelligence
you know like
he came in with the reputation as a
non-shooter but he always shot over 50
because you know he just
he knew what he did well and he and he
stuck to that and every year he added so
yeah
those would be my top four i may be
missing somebody somebody might put
jerry west in there
i i didn't i didn't see wes though
that's a little young for me
or old for me but um yeah those would be
mine
jeff van gundy here on the rich eisen
show uh
i guess before i let you go then the
trade deadline right after
uh coming up um you mentioned what you
think the nets can add obviously the
sixers or daryl moore is always
aggressive
um and then you got just two two
two questions on the subject one is
going to be i'll just front load the
the second one for you for you to think
about about what what if you could wave
a wand for one team what's the biggest
trade that you think
can be made that to affect uh the final
result
of this season that's number one but
right first up i mean blake griffin
and and andre drummond have been
basically told hey you're going to be
traded but we're not playing you until
then
i i i to me i find that outrageous jeff
i i just find that
outrageous that that two players um
are in situ sort of i guess a transfer
portal
if there's such a thing in the nba i've
never heard of such a thing i wonder
what you think of that subject matter
right well i i think i i'd be interested
in hearing
their take there's a big difference
between them wanting to play
and not being allowed to play right
versus
them understanding from a health
standpoint
um that if they got hurt it would
definitely
eliminate their chances probably to be
moved
i just think it's a slippery slope
that's not a good one for the nba
like it's the same with all the load
management stuff it's like
if you're healthy enough to play you
should play yeah and
um but obviously a lot of people don't
see it that way anymore
if if i was a player though um
i would want to play basketball so if i
was drummond
and uh blake griffin i'd want to be
playing
if i if i was healthy enough to
obviously and if i was healthy enough
i would like like i would be
you know uh very hard
if they kept telling me no um we're not
we're not playing you
now i just i guess the teams
have that right but if
uh i was the commissioner's office i'd
be very
concerned with a lot of these trends
that tell that we don't we're not
putting the best
players on the floor um for our fans
i think we have an obligation i think
it's gotten
lost um in all of this
and i think it's dangerous yeah i mean
what if the knicks back in the day told
you that you didn't have somebody
at your disposal because it was gonna
this guy's gonna get traded
you know what i'm saying look i know
that the the cavs want to see what they
have in jared allen and he's playing
well
i get it but i mean what what gives yes
if there's a difference between hey
we're trading this guy tonight right
don't play him tonight
and everybody understands that we may
trade him
in a month it's crazy yeah so we're not
playing him
and and i just think it it it goes
directly
to the integrity of the game and also
these guys i mean
draymond green i think spoke to this and
i don't know exactly what
um his points were as much um
but he spoke uh very vociferously about
that players need to be treated well too
and and
and part of that is if you give us our
best chance to win
in a coach's estimation we're playing
you
and because that's what our goal should
be which is to win games
to put our best players on the floor and
the best products we can for our fans
who are consumers who pay when they're
in the seat they pay
you know a lot of money um and when they
watch us on tv
they are giving up their time and i
think at times
we've started to take advantage of that
we haven't shown the respect we need to
to our fans um with these sorts of
shenanigans in the nba
and i i i disagree with it i think it's
very dangerous
so i guess both of those guys would be
phenomenal pieces to add i mean
give me give me one trade that you think
would be crucial
make a bit big difference or a team
should make before i let you go
jeff well blake griffin
obviously to me uh if he
if that knee holds up he can go
somewhere and i'm
i'm trying to think like you know
could he be you know like in miami
um a backup and play at times with
adebayo
um and give them even because one thing
about blake griffin that people
uh you know because they remember the
highlight dunks and all that
like he's improved as a three-point
shooter and he's a phenomenal passer
and when you can add passing
particularly at a big man's position
um then the versatility is so much
greater um so i think
i think he he would like for any of
those teams that
aren't achieving what they want to in
the east right now
um obviously you know the lakers could
he play
uh some there uh sure like i could see
him being able to fit in there as well
um so it'll be interesting too if these
guys if they don't get traded if they'll
accept a buyout and how much and
i don't like that whole buyout thing
either i think that's
that's a little murky too that
i don't think you should be a free agent
if you get bought out i think it should
be just like somebody got cut
the lowest team should be able to you
know have first rights
and dibs um so anyway
it'll be interesting though i think both
those guys both drummond and blake
griffin
in the right spots uh could be a help
obviously drummond if he could
if he gets bought out i think he would
go to brooklyn and
play a big role there wow lord jeff
thanks for the time
i really enjoyed it uh best to mike
breen and mark jackson everybody else
and let's chat down the line
thanks appreciate it right back at you
that's jeff van gundy everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here